Trascrizione: Roberto Minelli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Io mi chiamo Iacopo, con la "I".
No, non con la "J", con la "I".
Iacopo con la "I".
Nemmeno con la "K",
e nemmeno con la "E".
Iacopo con la "I" iniziale:
è semplicissimo, come una pizza
pomodoro e mozzarella.
No, non Iacopo con la "O":
Iacopo con la "I" iniziale.
Iacopo Melio.
Iacopo scritto con la "J"?
No, Iacopo con la "I".
Occhio, che ti "arroto"
con la mia carrozzina!
Pesa 200 chili,
e me la passano nuova
ogni mille anni, e che culo!
Sono ancora alla prima,
proprio perché sono Iacopo con la "I"
e ho 25 anni.
Il mio passaggio più bello
è stato quando sono nato,
anche se non mi ricordo niente.
Però è stato il viaggio-passaggio
che mi ha aperto
agli altri viaggi-passaggi.
Forse il più doloroso, non me lo ricordo,
ma sicuramente è stato
il viaggio-passaggio più bello.
E sono qui!
Adesso, sono qui con voi!
Buongiorno TED!
Non mi ricordo niente
del mio primo passaggio;
però so che, per i miei genitori,
la mia nascita fu uno shock.
Fu il ponte tra il prima e il dopo,
come quando ti prendono e ti sbattono
come un uovo sbattuto.
Come per ogni genitore,
la nascita di ogni figlio,
ma per loro un po’ di più.
E li capisco:
genitori di un bambino -
shhh, piano, piano -
con disabilità!
Con disabilità!
Fa paura a dirla così, eh?!
Accipicchia se fa paura!
Boia se spaventa!
Minchia signora...
Fa sempre paura ciò che non si sa
o non si conosce,
oppure ciò che guardiamo da lontano.
Perché è un modo per continuare
a non sapere o a non conoscere.
E allora io sono qui, stasera, con voi
per presentarmi e per avvicinarmi
e per farvi conoscere…
Tina, la mia carrozzina!
«Piacere, sono Tina».
Piacere, sono Iacopo, con la "I".
E non ho mai chiamato
"Tina" la mia carrozzina!
Perché sono disabile, ma non sono idiota!
Ma torniamo alla mia nascita.
Ci sono voluti quindici anni,
ai miei genitori, per riprendersi,
Poi è nata mia sorella
Costanza, con la "C".
Poi ho iniziato a mangiare, a parlare,
a scrivere, ad aprire una pagina facebook,
e a viaggiare, in un modo o nell’altro.
A costruire ponti,
in un modo o nell'altro.
Ho fondato la ONLUS
"Vorrei prendere il treno",
in un modo solo,
e da allora i miei genitori…
non si sono più ripresi!
Quando dico "viaggiare
in un modo o nell'altro"
intendo l’accessibilità,
con i suoi riflessi e i suoi connessi.
Io voglio ponti accessibili,
negozi accessibili,
altalene accessibili,
parchi e pinete come questa, accessibili,
cinema, bagni -
ma soprattutto voglio persone accessibili.
Toc, toc.
Chi è?
- Sto pisciando.
- In piedi o seduto?
- In piedi.
- Ecco, allora guarda: io sono fuori
dal bagno degli handicappati,
con la mia carrozzina.
E adesso ti aspetto,
così poi dopo ti "arroto".
Perché questo è il bagno
degli handicappati
e non è giusto che venga usato
dai non-handicappati
perché, semplicemente,
è più grande, più bello, più pulito.
- Ma io sono cieco!
- Ah!
Scusa! Ho fatto una figura di merda!
Continua pure a pisciare.
In piedi.
Perché i disabili sbagliano, come tutti;
sono stupidi, come tutti;
oppure sono intelligenti,
sono onesti o disonesti,
sono simpatici o antipatici.
Qualcuno è brutto,
qualcuno è bello,
qualcuno è molto, molto meglio, come me!
Qualcun altro è ironico o autoironico,
qualcuno è modesto.
A qualcuno gli piace la fica,
e a qualcuno gli piace il cazzo.
I disabili dicono le parolacce!
I disabili dicono le parolacce
soprattutto quando pensano
che possano funzionare in un monologo,
soprattutto come questo, per il TED.
I disabili non stanno sempre in casa,
i disabili non sono sempre tristi.
Ai disabili piacciono le tette -
questa non l’ho detta
per il monologo del TED.
Qualche disabile è triste,
qualcuno è tristissimo,
qualcuno sembra allegro,
ma ad ascoltarlo
ti fai due palle così!
Qualcuno non avrebbe niente da ridere,
eppure ti fa spanciare dalle risate;
ironico, allegro, divertente.
Qualcuno invece avrebbe molto,
molto da ridere;
eppure è di un depresso…
Aereo!
Questo è l’aereo. Lo sentite?
Anche sopra ai disabili passano gli aerei
e quindi dobbiamo aspettare
che l’aereo sia passato
per continuare
questo monologo del TED.
Adesso proviamo a sostituire
la parola "disabili" con "persone".
Vi aiuto io.
Qualche persona è triste,
qualcun’altra persona è tristissima;
qualche persona sembra allegra,
divertente, ironica
ma in realtà, ad ascoltarla
ti fai due palle così!
Qualche altra persona, invece,
ti fa scompisciare dalle risate
anche se, in realtà,
di motivi per ridere non ne avrebbe molti.
Qualcun’altra, invece,
di motivi ne avrebbe tanti,
per essere felice,
eppure è di un depresso...
Avete visto? Funziona lo stesso.
Perché se prima di una persona
vedete la sua disabilità,
allora significa
che il disabile siete voi.
Come quelli che mi scrivono:
"Oh, lo sai, ti ho visto... "
Ecco: sostituite i puntini di sospensione
con un posto qualsiasi,
e io in quel posto nemmeno ci sono stato.
Però loro hanno visto
una carrozzina, non me.
E quindi, mi hanno sostituito
a quella persona in carrozzina.
MA IO NON SONO LA MIA CARROZZINA!
Io non somiglio a quello
solamente perché è in carrozzina.
Anzi, per l’ordine della casualità,
è molto più probabile
che io non gli somigli affatto.
Poi, oh, ci sta - cioè, per carità,
Prendi Brad Pitt, gli rompi una gamba,
lo metti in carrozzina,
probabilmente io gli somiglio.
Anche se magari lui è biondo,
io sono moro…
"Allora, i disabili siete voi".
Ma io l’ho detta davvero
questa frase prima?
No, perché, connota negativamente
la disabilità.
"Allora, i disabili siete voi"...
Non mi piace,
io mi sono rotto i corbezzoli
di chi connota negativamente
una condizione
come quella della disabilità.
E come ho fatto io prima,
per amore di battuta,
in questo monologo del TED.
Oh! Anche i disabili sbagliano, eh!
Non sono tutti angeli,
e non hanno tutti ragione.
Anche se quando tu, non-disabile,
parcheggi la macchina
nel posto riservato ai disabili
e si arrabbiano,
allora sì, hanno tutti sempre ragione.
Aah, come vorrei
una bella carrozzina con le ali
per pisciare in testa
a chi parcheggia nei posti riservati
alle persone con disabilità.
Allora essere disabili è neutro?
No, qualcuno sceglierebbe la carrozzina
al posto delle gambe?
Non credo.
Però la disabilità è nata
dai negozi inaccessibili,
dalle altalene inaccessibili,
da cinema inaccessibili,
da ponti inaccessibili,
da parchi e da pinete come questa
che non è proprio
il massimo dell’accessibilità,
da persone inaccessibili.
E per questo e contro tutto questo
io mi sposto, parlo, scrivo, lotto -
mi piacciono le tette.
Perché i disabili possono anche ripetersi,
se le cose sono molto importanti,
se questa mosca ti dà fastidio,
o se le tette sono molto belle!
Io ho la fissa delle tette!
Volete sapere le cose che mi piacciono,
a parte le tette?
Sì? Vabbè, tanto ve lo dico lo stesso
perché questo è registrato
in una finta interazione
per richiamare l’attenzione.
Ecco, mi piace il profumo del mare
e mi piacciono le patatine fritte.
Le patatine fritte
perché mi ricordano quando da piccolo,
dopo le visite all'ospedale di Bologna,
andavo a mangiarle al McDonald’s -
ma questo non lo diciamo.
E oltre le patatine fritte,
mangiavo i toast,
quello rotondo, avete presente?
Ecco, sempre del McDonald’s -
e non lo diciamo.
E io vi sto raccontando tutto questo
in vacanza, in pineta,
davanti a una telecamera.
Ma non è strano un disabile
in vacanza, in pineta?
Ma anche la telecamera con il vento
che mi entra nel microfono.
Lo sentite questo vento?
Le macchine che passano,
e una cosa che sta passando adesso...
Se mi chiedi "mare o montagna?"
io ti rispondo "mare", ma dipende con chi!
Ecco, sì, anche i disabili
hanno una vita sessuale
e una vita sentimentale
che non è detto
che sempre coincidano.
Ah, se non avete capito,
ve la ridico più facile.
Perché questa è la parte fondamentale,
è il ponte e il passaggio
per capire e capirci.
Anche se non siamo una categoria -
capirci.
Perché ci sono persone innamorate,
che stanno insieme e fanno l’amore.
Persone non innamorate
che però fanno tanto sesso.
Persone innamorate che stanno insieme
senza fare l’amore.
E poi ci sono persone innamorate,
che stanno insieme,
fanno l’amore,
ma poi scopacchiano in giro, dove capita.
Ecco, e uno si chiede:
"Ma erano davvero innamorate?"
Io questo non lo so, non so rispondervi.
Ma già il fatto di avervi spostato
l’attenzione dalla disabilità,
credo sia un buon successo
per un gran fine monologo.
E volete sapere cos’è che non mi piace?
Non mi piace chi alza la voce.
Perché sono convinto
che le cose giuste, dette sotto voce,
facciano molto più rumore
delle cose sbagliate urlate.
Vi piace? È una frase mia!
L’ho inventata io!
Potete usarla.
Citatemi!
E volete sapere cos’è che mi fa paura?
Perdere i capelli.
Lo so che avrei mille altri
problemi a cui pensare,
ma l’idea di stempiarmi,
vedermi perdere i i capelli mi fa paura.
Perché mi ricorda il tempo che passa.
E l’idea che uno trascorra 30, 40, 50 anni
a costruire affetti, relazioni
che poi, in un attimo, possono sparire.
Pensavate, eh, di aver invitato
un disabile diverso,
che vi facesse ridere,
che vi parlasse di quanto è bella la vita,
che vi cantasse la canzoncina,
"Vengo anch’io, ta ta ra ta ra"...
E invece no!
Avete invitato un disabile
che vi parla di calvizie e di morte.
Tiè!
Un altro contro-pregiudizio buttato là,
nei cespugli, lì, in pineta.
Speriamo non sia infiammabile,
sennò con questo caldo piglia fuoco...
Non mi piace quando una persona ti dice:
"Non posso vivere senza di te"
E poi ti lascia,
e continua a vivere con un altro.
Mi piace molto quando una ragazza,
al primo appuntamento, mi dà un bel bacio.
E mi piace molto
quando una ragazza,
al primo appuntamento:
"Allora, un po’ di rispetto!"
Mi dà molto fastidio
quando le persone mi toccano i piedi.
No, non con le scarpe.
I piedi proprio... nudi.
E se lo fanno in genere
gli do un bel calcio.
Perché sono in carrozzina,
ma le gambe le muovo.
Ecco, tiè!
Un altro pregiudizio ammazzato.
Le unghie poi me le taglia la mia mamma,
perché sono pur sempre un italiano medio.
Sono stato in Croazia,
però vale poco perché ero in cima, in cima
quindi praticamente in Italia.
Però vorrei andare in Australia.
E vorrei tirare il granoturco
ai piccioni di Central Park.
Mi piace l’espressione di mia sorella
quando le rispondo: "sì"
al suo: "giochiamo?"
In realtà mi piacciono sempre,
le sue espressioni.
Sono fortunato ad avere
una sorella come te, Costanza.
Mi piacciono un sacco di cose,
ma adesso non posso dirvele tutte.
È tardi, voglio andare al mare,
il profumo del mare,
la sabbia, le patatine fritte.
Quindi, insomma, vi voglio bene
e un bacio a tutti!
Mi togliete una curiosità?
Ma dov’è Potenza?
L’ho messa su Google Maps,
e non lo trovava neanche.
Dai, sarete in 30, 40,
ci sarà un’età media di 50 anni!
Ma volete sapere
quanto si sta meglio al mare?
C'è delle ventenni!
Ma, ma, anzi, no, state a Potenza.
anche - viva il TED!
Viva il TED, viva Potenza!
Alè il TED, grande il TED, viva Potenza!
Alè il TED di Potenza!